rollins wachstums und
entwicklungsprozess der letzten
jahrzehnte war schwindel erringt seit
mustert 92 ist die polnische wirtschaft
im schnitt um über vier prozent pro jahr
gewachsen
damit wurde polen im vergleich zu
anderen europäischen staaten von einem
habe nichts zu einem der wohlhabendsten
länder dass nun knapp hinter irland
estland und lettland liegt das heißt
aber nicht dass sich die polen damit
zufrieden geben
tatsächlich liegen die kohlen auch wenn
es angesichts ihrer historischen
umstände überraschend erscheinen mag in
bezug auf das armutsrisiko bereits im
europäischen schnitt
in anderen worten polen gehört zu jener
gruppe von ländern die es geschafft
haben jene politischen wirtschaftlichen
und sozialen transformationsprozess zu
verdauen mit denen die länder des
ehemaligen ostblocks nach dem
zusammenbruch der udssr konfrontiert war
allerdings ist nicht alles was glänzt
auch pures gold polen kann mit
großartigen statistiken und
wirtschaftsdaten aufwarten
daran gibt es keinen zweifel in dieser
hinsicht sind sie unbestreitbar
erfolgreich aber wie sieht es mit dem
politischen und sozialen bereich aus
nun das ist genau der punkt an dem es
etwas trüber wird besonders wenn es um
bürgerrechte geht die meisten von euch
haben wahrscheinlich erkannt dass es
einfacher ist eine wirtschaft zu
transformieren als eine ganze
gesellschaft gesellschaftlicher wandel
dauert eben länger
wie wir sehen werden ist polen zusammen
mit ungarn wahrscheinlich das
konservativste und traditionsbewusste
land der gesamten europäischen union
das christentum ist teil unserer
nationalen identität die katholische
kirche war und ist der prediger und
träger des einzigen gemeinsamen werte
des systems in polen außerhalb davon ist
nur nelis muss jaroslaw kaczynski aber
es geht hier nicht nur um religionen
dieses land fährt seit einiger zeit eine
politische agenda die für viele direkt
mit den prinzipien der eu zusammen
geprallt
also wollt ihr mehr darüber erfahren was
in polen los ist wie konservativ ist die
politische gesellschaft wirklich worum
genau handelt es sich bei jener agenda
die den eu bürokraten so viele
kopfschmerzen bereitet nun in diesem
video erfahrt ihr alles wichtige darüber
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im grunde ist es so dass man es schwer
haben den polen wenn man nicht
katholisch weiß und heterosexuell ist
bohlens regierungspartei schürt die anti
lgbt stimmung vor den wahlen ein angel
tages politische wahl der vorsitzende
der regierenden partei recht und
gerechtigkeit polenz sieht in den
rechten der schwulen eine bedrohung für
die gesellschaft wie wir sie in diesem
land ist die ablehnung gegenüber allem
was über das traditionelle christliche
familien oder hinausgeht stark spürbar
in den meisten europäischen ländern wäre
es beispielsweise undenkbar dass die
haupt regierungspartei ldp dies als
bedrohung der gesellschaft bezeichnet
hier kommt dies jedoch jeden tag vor
denn die polnische politik ist manchmal
schwer zu verstehen
auf der einen seite sie wählen eine
führung die sich gegen die werte der
europäischen gemeinschaft stellt auf der
anderen seite ist die europäische union
bei den polen aber außerordentlich
beliebt sie der folgende sein
aber natürlich es ist nun mal die eine
sache die europäische union und ihre für
eine selbst angenehmen vorzüge zu mögen
und eine ganz andere bereit zu sein alle
von brüssel verordneten richtlinien
stricks zufolge sehen wir uns mal an wie
die polen damit umgehen
oberstes gericht der eu polen hat mit
der justizreform eu recht gebrochen
reuters polen und ungarn brachen eu
gesetze in den sie sich weigerten
migranten aufzunehmen
reuters holen widersetzt sich brüssel in
dem es an der kohle festhält
für polen ist die förderung seiner
abhängigkeit von russischer energie und
damit das festhalten an kohle wichtiger
als das co2 netto null ziel der eu
damit liegt warschau in der klimapolitik
auf kollisionskurs mit brüssel financial
times die europäische union ist bestrebt
faire regeln für ihre mitgliedstaaten zu
schaffen
und wenn es darauf ankommt wird polen
eben zum schurkenstaat erklärt aber wie
geht es zusammen dass die polen zwar
nicht viel von den richtlinien der eu
halten aber trotzdem eine derart
positive meinung über die europäischen
union selbst haben wir werden diesen
widerspruch auflösen
aber wir werden dies schritt für schritt
tun denn eins könnt ihr mir glauben
die polnische politik ist schon ein
wenig verrückt es ist mehr als zwei
jahre her seit brüssel polen wegen
seiner angeblich undemokratischen
tendenzen ermahnt hat könnte sich polen
dem autoritarismus zuwenden das ist die
erste grosse frage sind wir uns das mal
etwas näher an zustand der demokratie in
polen
es stellt sich heraus dass es einen
umstand gibt der viel viel wichtiger ist
als die loyalität polens gegenüber der
europäischen union was genau aber ist
beunruhigendes an der politischen
demokratie
genau gesagt der rabiate personalwechsel
in der staatsverwaltung durch die
polnische regierung zum beispiel
unternahm er slawinski der
vorstandsposten apps den versuch das
rentenalter von richter des obersten
gerichtshofs von 70 auf 65 jahre zu
senken und sich automatisch 40% errichte
zu entwickeln
[Musik]
denn diese müssten dann durch andere
richter ersetzt werden und die partei
wurde schon darauf achten dass nur ihr
genehme kandidaten dosen werden
die situation wurde so ernst dass der
europäische gerichtshof diese
gesetzesänderung stoppte da er sie als
klaren versuch von politischer kontrolle
über eine unabhängige justiz ansa die
regierung kaczynski gab jedoch nicht
klein bei und unternahmen weitere
versuche ihre kontrolle über das land zu
zementieren im jahr 2017 wurden vom
polnischen parlament sehr umstrittene
gesetze verabschiedet die darauf
abzielten der legislative und exekutive
also der regierung enorme macht über die
judikative zu verschaffen
wie wir alle wissen sollten diese
gewalten in einer gesunden demokratie
klar voneinander getrennt sein
da spricht man ja auch von
gewaltentrennung so sollte der
justizminister der übrigens auch
generalstaatsanwalt ist das recht
erhalten die richter und die präsidentin
der gerichte einen zu dürfen
ihr könnt euch vorstellen was dies in
bezug auf die politische kontrolle über
die gerichte bedeuten würde in einer
unerwarteten wendung der ereignisse
legte der präsident polens antreten
denn mit der ps eigentlich sympathisiert
aber kein parteimitglied ist sein veto
gegen zwei dieser drei gesetzte ein so
dass der justizminister
nur noch die gerichtspräsidenten nennen
konnte damit war die sache aber noch
nicht erledigt denn die polnische
regierung ist nach wie vor besessen
davon ihre kontrolle über die justiz
auszuweiten
[Musik]
bohlen für zeuge rungen unter die
staatsanwältin durch disziplinarkammer
für polnische richter ist nicht
unabhängig sagt der oberste berater des
europäischen gerichtshofs financial
times man könnte sagen dass die eu wegen
all dieser probleme zum frontalangriff
auf polen übergegangen ist tatsächlich
aktivierte brüssel zum ersten mal in
seiner geschichte
jene disziplin a mechanismus gegen ein
mitgliedsland was mit der aussetzung der
stimmrechte polens bei europäischen
entscheidungen enden könnte
holen angeblicher politischer kontrolle
der justiz vor dem obersten gericht es
ist sehr beunruhigend wenn politiker
sich ins justizsystem einmischen nicht
nur in polen
der eu geht es aber nicht nur um die
sicherung der gewaltenteilung in polen
die liberalen befürchten unruhen da die
katholische kirche polens bei ihrer
schwulenfeindlichen rhetorik noch eins
draufsetzt der erzbischof von krakau
marek jeder schewski sieht polen in
einem belagerungszustand durch eine
regenbogen klage von schwulenrechtler
die er mit dem ehemaligen
kommunistischen herrschen polens
verglich reuters um zu gewinnen
dämonisiert bei polens bevorstehenden
wahlen die partei recht und
gerechtigkeit die lgbt community for and
policy
[Musik]
im grunde strem polen und die eu
politisch in vollkommen entgegengesetzte
richtung
so und nun ist es endlich an der zeit
die frage zu beantworten warum die
europäische union dann bei den polen zu
unglaublichem beliebtheitswerte genießt
fakt ist dass die ps die regierung und
damit die mehrheit der polnischen
gesellschaft nicht alles ablehnt was die
europäische union zu bieten hat
tatsächlich gibt es etwas das ihnen
anscheinend sehr gefällt hört jetzt gut
zu
[Musik]
geld jede
in europa ist die kritik an der eu gar
nichts außergewöhnliches in jedem
mitgliedsstaat wird die eu für ihre
nachteile beschimpft während man die
vorteile gerne mitnimmt
die polin schießen hierbei jedoch den
vogel ab aber das geld oder das geld das
ist eine andere sache
das geld der eu wird natürlich gerne
genommen die willkommens klatscher des
geldes in polen bereiten ihm einen
herzlichen empfang und wir reden hier
nicht über klimper geld seit dem
beitritt polens zur eu hat das land
schon mehr als 100 milliarden euro an
gemeinschafts beihilfen erhalten allein
der europäische kohäsionsfonds hat pohl
für den zeitraum von 2014 bis 2020 mehr
als 80 milliarden euro für die
finanzierung von infrastrukturprojekten
die autobahnen und verbindungen zur
verfügung gestellt tatsächlich erhält
polen mehr mittel aus dem kohäsionsfonds
als jedes andere eu land nebenbei
bemerkt waren diese beihilfen entgegen
der landläufigen meinung nicht der
schlüssel zum wirtschaftlichen
aufschwung ist ganz und gar nicht aber
sie haben ein wenig dabei geholfen und
das wirft eine frage auf die immer mehr
politiker in der eu aufhorchen lässt
sollte die eu ist zur bedingung machen
finanzielle hilfen nur denjenigen
männern
zu gewähren die sich bereit erklären
alle regeln und beschlüsse der union zu
befolgen sollte brüssel die gelder
einfrieren die an mitgliedsstaaten mit
die liberalen regierungen vergehen
werden nun es sieht so aus als ob es in
diese richtung gehen würde
brüssel sagt polen die eu sei keine kuh
die man melken kann
deutsche welle tatsache ist dass gerade
jetzt die bedingungen und die verteilung
des eu kommission für den zeitraum von
2021 bis 2027 handelt werden und ist
dies so aus als ob polen dabei nicht gut
abschneiden wird
bohlen erhält 23 prozent weniger im
haushalt der eu 2020 bis 2027 financial
ob server
falls sich diese nachricht bestätigt
könnte polen also fast ein viertel der
gelder verlieren die es derzeit von der
europäischen union erhält wohl es mit
etwas mehr als 60 milliarden euro
weiterhin der größte nettoempfänger sein
würde
aber auch diese haushaltskürzung ist
nicht das was sie zu sein scheint dieser
schritt hat eigentlich nichts mit einer
bestrafung oder ähnlichem zu tun sondern
mit der tatsache dass polen über euch
bereits am anfang des videos erklärt
haben heute ein reicheres land ist mit
einer besseren infrastruktur und näher
am entwicklungs durchschnitt der übrigen
europäischen union
das und die tatsache dass brüssel
nachdem rexit gezwungen ist den gürtel
enger zu schnallen
da ist nicht mehr mit den jährlichen
beitrag großbritanniens zur
gemeinschaftskasse rechnen kann auf
jeden fall stellt sich die frage würde
eine verringerung der eu mittel
angesichts der tendenzen der polnischen
gesellschaft zur ablehnung des aus
brüssel diktierten wegs dieses land
nicht noch weiter von der union
entfernen werden die nationalistischen
parteien in polen diese kürzungen nicht
einfach als beweis für eine einmischung
der eu in eine polnische belange
ausschlachten und die wichtigste frage
von allen sind die politischen
ausrichtungen polens und ungarns ja die
politik alle beschicker starten
insgesamt überhaupt ein bar mit dem rest
mit den westlichen teil der europäischen
union oder was zumindest nachdem briggs
ist davon übrig geblieben ist wir freuen
uns über eure angeregte diskussionen
dazu im kommentarbereich abonniert
visual politik und drückt auf die
klingel taste wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat dann gebt uns einen daumen
hoch und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]